"The Witcher's" Yennefer of Vengerberg has
a brutal and generally unforgiving life.
Originally cursed and ostracized by her
community for her elvish blood, Yennefer
is further outcasted from society thanks to
being born with a hunchback and an awkward gait.
Her family later sells her
to the passing mage Tissaia,
the headmistress of Aretuza,
an academy for female mages.
Tissaia senses an untapped potential
in the brow-beaten Yennefer, though
her new life at Aretuza is, at first,
little better than the one she had.
Ambitious to a fault and craving great
power, Yennefer uses a combination of guile,
intimidation, and cunning in Season
1 to finally learn to use magic,
while at the same time transforming her visage to
become beautiful, though at great personal cost.
Season 2 picks up after Yennefer taps
into the forbidden magic of fire,
which saves the day and stops
the Nilfgaardian advance,
but leaves her bereft of the magic
that defines so much of her existence.
Once again, Yennefer is put in a place where she
is willing to do anything to get her power back.
It all sets the stage for a
season 2 scene that had even
the biggest Yennefer fans worried about
how the show is handling her character.
The second episode of Season 2, "Kaer Morhen",
sees Yennefer, Fringilla, and Francesca invoke
a supposedly ancient elvish deity. But when they
do, the apparition conjured whisks the three away,
and offers each of them their hearts' desire,
though it is implied there will be a cost.
"If that's your play, it's rather desperate."
"You're the desperate one, Yennefer – the most."
Both Fringilla and Francesca agree,
but Yennefer initially refuses.
However, Yennefer is later captured
and about to be executed when she
invokes the litany that summons the
"Deathless Mother," who promises to
return magic to Yennefer in exchange for
a young girl whom she doesn't recognize.
Yennefer reluctantly agrees, and
the desperation in her eyes is
palpable. This is a pretty big sacrifice that
would make even the evilest person wince,
but Yennefer is willing to do
anything at this point in Season 2.
She eventually comes across
her target. In a twist of fate,
it turns out to be Geralt's adoptive child, Ciri.
The Deathless Mother feeds off pain and
suffering, and, had Yennefer sacrificed Ciri,
there would have been tremendous
pain for both Geralt and herself.
To a degree, Yennefer's actions shouldn't
come as too much of a surprise. In Season 1,
audiences saw how Yennefer reacts to a world that
treats her with cruelty before she transforms.
After she changes, with the physical
traits society once shunned her for now
fixed, she goes on to embrace her power as a
sorceress, using her magic for both good and ill.
Yennefer's shocking turn, however brief,
left fans of "The Witcher" polarized.
Her ability to toe the line between
hero and villain is intriguing,
and part of what makes her such a
complex and compelling character.
It was this complex nature that had fans
reacting right and left on Reddit. Many
expressed how upset they were with this scene and
its implications on her character arc in Season 2.
On the subreddit r/netflixwitcher,
one Redditor wrote,
"Really disappointed in Yen this season and
I thought she was one of the best characters
in season 1. I was really looking forward to
her teaching Ciri about magic [...] but that
storyline was basically compressed into two or
three scenes when they were riding to Cintra.
Also did not like that Yen was planning
to sacrifice Ciri to get her powers back.
This really puts a weird strain on
their relationship from here on out."
Another user offered a rebuttal, saying,
"But then Yen warned Ciri, and later sacrificed
herself for her. Plus Geralt loves her, meanwhile,
Yen is so impressed and enamored by
Ciri that all will be soon forgotten.
It's hard to hate someone who
actively and obviously adores you."
A different poster acknowledged that the
show develops Yennefer and Ciri's dynamic
differently than the way it develops in
Andrzej Sapkowski "The Witcher" books. There,
Yennefer has a more friendly, almost maternal
stance and helps Ciri learn about her magic.
As we see in this particularly divisive Season
2 scene, Yennefer's actions lay the foundation
for a different tone in her relationship
with Ciri. As the Reddit user wrote,
"In the show, she doesn't know Ciri
and she's desperate to get her powers.
People make stupid decisions when they're
desperate so I get what they were trying
to do here. Would I have preferred
if they kept the book version? Yes."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.